now even though Clark County officials
reiterate that supplies in our area will
not see a big impact just yet that
didn't stop some from getting out and
filling up just in case Brian will was
out
into residence as they waited in line to
fill up Brian
these pumps behind me don't look as busy
as they did earlier tonight as people
flocked to the gas stations to fill up
after news of the pipeline
I heard there's a rumor about gas some
issue gas lines so I just I'm
almost no gas so I wanted to make sure I
fill up the tank confusion at the pumps
Friday night as some places across the
valley saw long lines but others
completely empty I was really surprised
of the three gas stations that I went
and there were empty it started when
Clark County officials announced they
were aware of a leak affecting a Kinder
Morgan gas pipeline in California that
pipeline feeds gas storage facilities
with unleaded and diesel fuel here in
southern Nevada it's one of two major
pipelines that feed our area the other
comes from Utah the long lines caused
Panic buying in certain parts of the
area like the Northwest Valley I think
it's all a hype but I just don't want to
be caught off guard are you on the
closer to e right now no I'm half I'm
actually three quarters Clark County
says they are monitoring the situation
and they believe there is an adequate
supply of gasoline officials don't
expect an impact on fuel availability
but that didn't stop people from filling
up anyway any advice yeah don't buy into
it
like I did
now the busiest stations that we came
across today were north of downtown and
west of the 95 also some busy spots over
down in Henderson as well now if you do
come across some stations with a little
bit of a line they don't have gas you
can always travel around and see like
behind me there are still plenty of
stations around that do have gas you can
go get to so you can just travel around
if you do come across those longer lines
live in Spring Valley Brian will 8 news
now Brian thanks for that an
investigation into the cause of that
leak is underway officials say any
impact though should be limited in our
area